alors Sylvie launa vous êtes directrice
d'Yves tourisme vous allez faire le
point sur les idées sorties du week-end
et des prochains jours le soleil revient
timidement j'espère qu'on va pouvoir en
profiter quels sont les événements
incontournables alors effectivement on
espère que le que le soleil revient
puisque des randonnées sous le soleil
c'est quand même beaucoup plus agréable
que des randonnées sous la pluie donc on
a une première manifestation qui
s'appelle Tous en scène à travers la
vallée de la Maule c'est demain et donc
tous en scène ça n'est pas que tous en
scène finalement parce qu'il y a aussi
une randonnée pédestre donc vous passez
par différents chemins cette organisé
par la ville de Beynes la randonnée
cyclo par exemple passe par les châteaux
de Beynes de Villiers-Le-Mahieu de
Thoiry donc on découvre à l'occasion de
ces randonnées les paysages les petits
villages les beaux les beaux paysages en
gros de ce coin des Yvelines d'accord il
y a aussi un rallye pédestre alors il y
a un rally pédestre qui lui se déroule à
Septeuil alors ce rallye pédestre
accepte il va vous permettre de
découvrir des ruines gallo-romaines
aussi un château du 19e qui a été
construit sur les ruines d'une abbaye
bénédictine donc beaucoup beaucoup de
choses encore très très variées en forme
son équipe entre deux et cinq personnes
et voilà et on va randonner on peut
aussi découvrir les jardins anglais à
Thoiry voilà alors c'est pareil c'est
une randonnée à pied mais alors on peut
faire à pied mais de manière très
différente c'est-à-dire on peut faire de
la marche nordique on peut courir on
peut y aller à pied en balade
tranquillement on découvre les jardins
anglais et après on découvre
effectivement à cette occasion tout
toute la végétation les arbres et les
plantes de Thoiry on va même jusqu'au
château de villiers-le-mailleux ce sont
les foulées sauvages de Thoiry et on
peut aussi
assister à tous en scène du côté de la
scène cette fois voilà alors tous en
scène cette organisé par le smso et donc
ce sont divers parcours de randonnées
qui se déroulent le long de la Seine
c'est entre 3 et 62 km donc c'est pour
les petits randonneurs ou les vrais
vrais vrais cyclistes et donc c'est la
journée du 2 dimanche prochain ou tous
les cyclistes pourront se donner
rendez-vous il y a aussi une randonnée
plus sur la thématique littéraire cette
fois alors la thématique littéraire oui
est abordée par la ville d'Andrésy avec
pour inspiration Marcel Alain et qui a
écrit les célèbres Fantômas et donc
notamment on va on va les découvrir mais
en découvrera encore plus de plus de
choses au niveau de la végétation
puisqu'on va apprendre un petit bateau
pour traverser la scène et aller sur
linancy ligne Nancy c'est merveilleux en
végétation et on a l'impression qu'on
est hors du temps et on va faire la
randonnée justement sur cette île Nancy
et c'est extrêmement dépaysant on a même
l'impression d'être en vacances une
randonnée nature peinture oui alors
c'est à la fois nature mais un tout
petit peu culture puisque cette
randonnée
soit à la journée soit à la demi-journée
va vous permettre de découvrir des
petites scénettes impressionnistes
puisque ce sont des acteurs qui vont
ponctuer la randonnée en question alors
cette randonnée par de Bonnières le
matin c'est une randonnée ici on l'a
fait à la journée qui fait 22 km et puis
l'après-midi si on veut faire une moins
grosse randonnée de 10 km seulement par
de la base de loisirs de moisson et donc
animé avec des petites dégustations de
produits du terroir avec avec des
petites animations c'est très sympa
surtout qu'il prévoit à la météo du beau
temps espérons un autre événement à ne
pas manquer une soirée Far West oui ce
sont les nuits de Monte-Cristo alors
c'est non seulement une soirée Far West
là où on va découvrir tout ce que
faisait les trappeurs les cowboys avec
du tir à l'arc des scènes de dressage
des cascades donc on a l'impression on
se retrouve
au XVIIIe siècle aux États-Unis et puis
tout ça se clôture au château de
Monte-Cristo par un embrasement du
château donc c'est extrêmement joli et
un peu et un peu magique on parlait tout
à l'heure des randonnées à cheval entre
autres on peut aussi rencontrer les
étalons du Haras national des Bréviaires
oui alors le haras national des
Bréviaires proposent une visite des
haras le premier juin c'est-à-dire
demain plus tous les tous les mercredis
qui suivent jusqu'à la fin du mois et là
on peut découvrir les étalons en
dressage mais aussi en toute liberté et
ensuite on découvre visite guidée la
sellerie les écuries avec des petits
ateliers donc de quoi passer un bon
moment dans un environnement qui qui
vous décale complètement de la réalité
et du quotidien je crois que vous avez
aussi un petit événement à découvrir de
toute urgence du côté de Versailles
alors à Versailles il y a eu l'ouverture
il y a très peu de temps il doit y avoir
une quinzaine de jours environ de la
cour des senteurs alors la cour des
senteurs propose et particulièrement
Guerlain propose des petits déjeuners
découvertes le petit déjeuner est un
petit déjeuner le hauno donc pas
n'importe lequel et après on découvre
dans l'enceinte du magasin Guerlain qui
est magnifique à l'image de ce qu'on
peut découvrir à Versailles avec des
jolies boiseries des flacons merveilleux
et on découvre l'histoire du parfum de
ce parfumeur qui qui était vraiment très
innovant à son époque donc c'est un
moment de de petits luxes entre
guillemets et de détente voilà à la cour
des senteurs par Guerlain très bien je
vous remercie Sylvie laouna pour tous
ces toutes ces dates à retenir pour les
prochains jours